je suis triste de voir que benoît hamon
passe les trois quarts de sa campagne à
taper sur emmanuel macron alors que il a
décidé il a fait un choix de
réorientation politique très à gauche
mais dans ces cas là qui fasse sa
campagne là dessus et qu'ils fassent des
propositions qu'ils arrêtent de deux
frappé les abruzzes alors que mais oui
oui il faut arrêter cette bagarre là
notre ennemi c'est l'extrémisme c'est le
front national c'est la droite
recroquevillé et bourré d'affaires de
françois fillon c'est ça c'est ça notre
ennemi commun et au bout d'un moment il
faut oui on se trompe on se trois
ennemis de terminer grand mais
d'adversaire en tout cas